our Russian forces are still believed to
control around 70 percent of The Wider
donbass region in the wake of the
withdrawal the ministry defense has said
it's highly likely that moscow's troops
destroyed Road and rail bridges over the
nepro river as part of their Retreat
while retired Air Vice Marshall Sean
Bell joins us now good to see the
Saturday morning Sean and the footage is
extraordinary isn't it coming out of
hers on very very emotional to watch it
looks like a significant defeat for
President Putin what's your take on it
well it's no doubt this is a decisive
Victory this was the only major regional
it was the capital that Russia had
seized and this is going to be very
difficult for Russia to play
domestically back at home Ukraine still
has to deal with a number of booby traps
probably the reports of a lot of Russian
soldiers have been left behind and
therefore either been pushed into
civilian clothes or potentially Special
Forces and but we have more so we talked
a bit about the Kharkov Ka Dam up to the
north there that if the Russians were to
blow that Dam then that could flood
whole region as well which create a
whole world of problems that has been
blown slightly but we haven't heard more
than that but apart from securing the
city there's no doubt the the this is a
euphoric day but but from a military
perspective I think we have to be
careful that actually it probably suited
both ukrainians and the Russians for the
Russians to withdraw from the city and
when you say suited the Russians what do
you mean well um Peter's military
strategy almost certainly is to try to
focus up on the donbass that and he's
been struggling up there as you reported
there's a big chunk of the Don bass that
he hasn't actually taken yet that is his
main effort and if he could withdraw 30
000 troops that were largely stagnant
sitting doing nothing in Harrison and
get them out in good order redeploy them
up to the up to the north of the donbass
that could create some really really
difficult problems for the ukrainians uh
up there but from president zlinski off
from Harrison has been his main effort
he would not have wanted to fight his
way in there and therefore moving in
unopposed as it were is great news the
the really difficult thing as well
militarily if you remember up in the
north when the rush withdrew from
kharkiv they ran away and the Ukraine is
chased after them was a bit of a route
and they achieved a massive amount of
territory focus and that's not going to
be possible because you as you reported
that danipe River the bridges have been
blown and of course Russians have been
digging in defensive positions on the
far side of that River doing an opposed
amphibious assault onto that would be
incredibly difficult to do so it's not
going to be possible to follow that up
and what's evident now is Russia is
digging in defensive lines all over the
place both under denipro and the donbass
and protecting and what appears to be
the case is Russia wants to be able to
spin this as a success for his special
military operation turn man domestically
and say success and pause
nevertheless though it is a massive
defeat for them isn't it just six weeks
after claiming you know victory in terms
of annexing this particular area the big
question is what's next it seems that
Ukraine has the momentum on its side
what happens next yeah and this is the
24 000 question isn't it I mean with
winter fast approaching Russia is
digging in defensive positions and that
will make very difficult for Ukrainian
attacks against established defensive
positions and there's going to be a
feels like a bit of a stalemate Brewing
at the moment from a Russian perspective
they um probably are getting close to
the position where they'd be happy to
negotiate but from a Ukrainian
perspective presidents lensky almost
certainly their tails are up they're
talking about and vanquishing every
single Russian even from Crimea but it's
worth pointing out for a military
perspective Crimea withstood attacks
from Whole armies in the Second World
War those defensive positions still
exist it's very difficult to see how
Ukraine will ever be able to take that
anytime soon the donbass is a different
matter it's been a fall in the side for
zlinski for ages and besides both sides
need weapons Russia's trying to get them
for Iran the Ukraine is getting them
from the west but it's telling that
asylinski hasn't been prepared to talk
to Putin yet increasing pressure on the
domestic International stage
particularly from the United States to
try to get him to pick up that phone
almost certainly won't negotiate a
settlement yet military fight these
battles the politicians come to horrible
compromise we're getting closer to the
day when at least talks are going to
have to start happening yeah indeed Sean
we'll see you in the next half now
though thank you very much